You need footage.
You need footage, bro, so people don't...
Look at this.
Damn, these kids just got trucked.
That's pretty brutal.
They've never beat us before, I don't blame them.
Bro.
Damn.
That's tough.
Sad day to be an alumni right now.
Talk to somebody, I think.
I must see if Will can sneak us a couple pizzas.
That was a win or a go, Joe.
See, this is one of the years in my life.
Like, I'm never gonna go to a college football hotel.
And they're gonna have multiple losses.
The high school system's weird.
You get your invite based on the year before.
The year before.
Yeah.
So it's like, I think two people are gonna win in high school.
Basically.
You know.
It goes.
It's kinda like a monopoly.
A pace!
That was a bad one.
That wasn't even my day.
But admittedly I waited a day for this trip.
Being the captain?
수를.
And to be
seviable.
Oh.
That's such horror.
It is kinda sick.
That is kinda sick.
That's a huge win for them, they've never done that shit before, so are you gonna repose
for Memorial Day or what?
Yeah, I'm down.
Are you down?
No, Memorial Day Beach.
I'm down.
Do you think they're gonna take it off Friday?